[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله
يعني في هذه الصور ايضا
يبدو بانه هناك الاشخاص ياخذون بعض
الاكياس القمح من هذه المخازن ربما التي
لم تتضرر يعني على الرغم من القصف ولكن
نشاهد ايضا الناس حول هذه المخازن
لا نعرف اذا كانت هذه الاكياس هي ايضا
لقمح او لامور اخرى
هل يحاولون الخروج من هذه المنطقه الى
منطقه اخرى لا ندري ولكن هذا ما نتبعه في
هذا الفيديو الذي يقال بانه لمنطقه سيقه
في الخرطوم بحري حيث تتواجد مخازن للقمح
وكنا في بدايه هذا الفيديو
تابعنا
مشهد المخازن وهو معرض للاحتراق
هذا الفيديو يظهر
نهب مخازن سيقه
القمح في الخرطوم بحري
يعني على الرغم من هذا القصف واحتراق
المخازن ولكن هناك حركه من السكان من حوله
هذا هو المبنى المحترق للمخازن التي تحتوي
على القمح في الخرطوم بحري مخازن سيقا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات